what would be the worst thing that we
could do why you ask a Lila's this type
of girl that beats to her own dress hi
my name is Lila and I like to do art and
I also like to do gymnastics if I design
my own bedroom the bed would have
rainbow bedding like a rainbow canopy
because when I go to bed I usually look
up at the ceiling like that I want
rainbows all over my room rainbows
everywhere and if I don't get rainbows
and always had she's always been drawing
rainbows yeah she's had one over her bed
for a long time Lila's current bedroom
is very basic that's why she draws so
much to color her room she doesn't use
it right now because it's not to her
taste Lila is currently sharing a bunk
bed with her brother she'll be really
excited she's been wanting this for a
really long time she's also the middle
child right so a lot of stuff like her
brothers will get so this is something
that's totally about her I think her
bedroom will be a reflection of her
because she just has that brightness
about her we're really excited to see
what you guys do I think is gonna be so
fun and Lila is gonna be ecstatic are
you gonna miss your brother when you
move out no so Lila yeah should we go
see what it looks like yeah
[Music]
this is not exactly what I expected but
I loved it way more you got a new light
and the stars let's check out the best
amazing this is like the best day of my
life let's see what it looks like in the
dark night mode Oh find it I felt I was
actually like at the end of the rainbow
finding my pot of gold from a scale of 1
to 10 I'd give it a 20 I was very
surprised surprised it's amazing all the
little touches everything is so
beautiful I feel like if I look up until
I reach the end of the canopy